bien tendremos un problema lo que
sabemos es que el ángulo teta
está entre menos tres y medios y menos
pi está en medio de estos dos valores
sabemos que el c9 teta es igual a un
medio y que la tangente de teta es justo
lo que queremos encontrar ahora sería
muy bueno que tú intentaras resolver
este ejercicio por ti solo y para eso te
recomiendo que pausas el vídeo justo
ahorita para que tú intentes tú mismo
ahora si no sabes bien por dónde va este
problema te puedo dar un tip mi consejo
es que utilices la identidad
trigonométricas pitagórica
bien espero que ya hayas pausado el
vídeo porque ahora voy a intentar
resolverlo yo así que utilizamos lo que
sabemos
sabemos que el seno de ted es igual a un
médium entonces
utilizando la identidad trigonométricas
pitagórica que hemos encontrado bastante
nos dice lo siguiente el seno cuadrado
de un ángulo ok a esto le agregamos le
agregamos el coseno cuadrado de un
ángulo el coseno cuadrado de un ángulo
esto me tiene que dar exactamente igual
que uno de lujo y de aquí ya sabemos el
seno de este ángulo el seno este ángulo
es un medio así que vamos a utilizarlo
aquí me va a quedar un medio un medio
esto elevado al cuadrado más más el
coseno elevado al cuadrado de ese ángulo
más
el coseno cuadrado de ese ángulo esto es
igual a 1 esto es igual a 1
bien ahora lo que quiero encontrar es el
valor del coseno cuadrado de este ángulo
para así encontrar el valor del coseno
de este ángulo y por eso pues voy a
elevar a éste al cuadrado y un medio
elevado al cuadrado es exactamente lo
mismo que un cuarto un cuarto más
el coseno cuadrado más el coseno o
déjame cambiar de color
más el coseno cuadrado de este ángulo
esto debe de ser igual a 1 ok y ahora si
restó un cuarto de ambos lados de esta
ecuación voy a obtener aunque el coseno
cuadrado que el cruce no cuadrado de
este ángulo teta es exactamente igual es
exactamente igual que uno menos un
cuarto lo cual es tres cuartos tres
cuartos ok y si ahora quiero encontrar
el coseno de este ángulo entonces voy a
decir que el coche no detectan ya sin el
cuadrado va a ser igual va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada a la raíz cuadrada de
tres cuartos pues recuerda que cuando yo
me tengo una raíz cuadrada
tengo dos valores uno positivo y uno
negativo a más menos la raíz cuadrada de
tres cuartos y justo lo que quiero saber
es si esto es positivo o negativo ok que
por cierto esto es exactamente lo mismo
y lo puedo escribir así esto es
exactamente lo mismo que más menos la
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre entre la raíz
cuadrada de 4 lo cual es 2
ok ejemplo en el puesto color entre 2
este estrés este estrés ok y bueno atrás
lo que voy es a ver si esta raíz
cuadrada es positiva o negativa y ya que
lo sepan una vez que tenga el coche no
va a ser muy fácil que yo pueda calcular
la tangente porque la tangente es el
seno entre el coseno entonces se nos dé
teta que es un medio entre el cruce 90
que es este de aquí voy a obtener así la
tangente para eso necesito saber qué
valor tiene este signo de aquí si es
positivo o negativo y para eso voy a
utilizar la información que no he
utilizado
todavía lo que todavía no utilizo es que
este ángulo teta está entre menos tres
primeros y menos pin y para eso voy a
utilizar a mi círculo unitario para ver
dónde estamos parados así que déjame
dibujarlo por aquí este es mi eje de
leyes algo así ok
este es mi eje de las x ok algo así este
punto no existe así que déjenme borrarlo
ok
y ahora voy a poner que este es el eje y
este es el eje x y voy a poner mi
círculo unitario y para eso déjenme
cambiar de color y me gusta este de que
el círculo unitario más o menos así ok
ahora cuando nosotros tenemos un ángulo
recuerda que el primer lado de este de
este ángulo que va a formar a este
ángulo lo fijo en el eje de las equis ok
este lado ya lo voy a fijar justo aquí y
ahora el otro al lado lo voy a variar
hasta llegar a un valor de teta que esté
entre menos tres promedios y menos pin
así que para camps para acá hacia atrás
a menos y medios para acá para que tenga
menos para bien ya nos vamos acercando y
para acá y este de aquí es menos tres
primeros a ver déjame ponerlo con
colores a este de aquí este de aquí este
es menos pin es menos pin ok este de
aquí este de aquí este este es al menos
tres primeros ok y el ángulo está entre
estos dos así que el ángulo que busco
está en medio de ellos dos es más o
menos así es un ángulo que esté en medio
de estos dos ok ahora este ángulo que
tengo aquí lo que quiero que veas son
más bien lo que nos vamos a fijar es en
su respectivo valor en este punto
recuerda que nos fijamos en este punto
donde interceptamos al círculo unitario
y justo en ese punto sabemos que tenemos
coordenadas tenemos coordenadas coseno
detectan que es con este color
jose no de teta coma seno de teta coma
seno de eta son las coordenadas de este
punto justo así definimos a las
funciones trigonométricas en el círculo
unitario y ahora nos queremos fijar en
el coste no de teta pero el coche no
detecta es el posible valor que puede
tomar en el eje de las x es decir que si
nosotros bajamos por aquí el coste no de
teta es este valor de equipo éste es
nuestro valor del coste no beteta de
este ángulo ahora lo que quiero que veas
es que este coste de 90 está
especialmente negativo porque estamos
atrás del origen y por lo tanto este
valor debe de ser negativo que es justo
lo que buscábamos saber si el coche 90
era negativo positivo y cómo estamos
atrás del origen es un valor negativo y
por lo tanto puedo quitar este de aquí
este de aquí y ahora si ya puedo
concluir que el coche no detecta que el
coche no detecta es exactamente igual
déjame cambiar de color es exactamente
igual que raíz de 3 entre 2 que raíz de
3 entre 2
negativo negativo ahora si no me voy a
fijar en la versión positiva y ya con
esto voy a poder encontrar la tangente
de teta porque yo sé que la tangente es
exactamente lo mismo y voy a poner esto
es igual al seno de teta que es un medio
a un medio entre entre el coche no
beteta que es menos raíz de 3 entre 2 a
menos raíz de 3 entre 2 y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo esto es exactamente
lo mismo que tener un medio antes de
ponerlo por acá que tener un medio y
multiplicarlo a dejar el cambio de color
esto es exactamente lo mismo y
multiplicarlo por el recíproco de éste
es decir 2 entre menos raíz de 3 ok lo
cual por cierto es exactamente lo mismo
es exactamente lo mismo este 2 con este
2 se va y me queda menos uno entre raíz
qué es lo que yo quería la tangente de
teta es menos 1 / raíz de 3 aunque hay
muchas personas que no les gusta tener
una raíz abajo y para eso vamos a
racionalizar y voy a multiplicar por
raíz de 3 arriba y abajo
ok solamente para quitar esta raíz de 3
de aquí abajo y esto me va a quedar que
es exactamente lo mismo que menos la
raíz de tres menos la raíz de tres y
raíz de tres por raíz de tres me queda 3
- la raíz de 3 entre 3 de lugo es justo
lo que yo quiere encontrar la tangente
de theta que es justo lo que yo quiera
encontrar es igual a menos la raíz de 3
sobre 3 que es justo lo que tengo aquí
es más déjame ponerlo aquí la tangente
de theta la tangente de teta es igual a
menos la raíz de 3 sobre 3 que es justo
lo que queríamos y bueno tiene todo el
sentido lógico del mundo porque la
tangente de theta representa
precisamente la pendiente de esta recta
que tengo aquí ya llegamos al resultado